THIS IS THE FIVE.
♪
>> MAIN STREAM MEDIA BEING
ACCUSED OF A MAJOR DOUBLE
STANDARD OVER ITS COVID
COVERAGE.
OUTLETS HARDLY MENTIONING BARACK
OBAMA'S 60TH BERTH DAY PARTY IN
MARTHA'S VINEYARDS WHERE HE WAS
DANCING WITHOUT A MASK AMONG A
CROWD.
ONE NEW YORK WRITER IS FACING
BACKLASH ABOUT HOW SHE IS
DEFENDING THESE SCALED DOWN
CELEBRATIONS.
>> OTHER PEOPLE SAID, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS REALLY BEING OVERBLOWN.
THEY'RE FOLLOWING ALL THE SAFETY
PRECAUTIONS.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO SPORTING
EVENTS THAT ARE BIGGER THAN
THIS.
THIS IS GOING TO BE SAFE.
THIS IS A SOPHISTICATED
VACCINATED CROWD AND THIS IS
JUST ABOUT OPTICS, NOT ABOUT
SAFETY.
>> THE PRESS TAKING A DIFFERENT
APPROACH WHEN IT COMES TO GOP
GOVERNORS BY DIRECTLY BLAMING
THEM FOR THE SPREAD OF THE NEW
CORONAVIRUS STRAIN.
>> GREG ABBOTT IS IN A RACE TO
BE THE WORST POSSIBLE GOVERNOR
IN THE COUNTRY AND THE ONLY ONE
HE HAS COMPETITION WITH RIGHT
NOW IS GOVERNOR DeSANTIS IN
FLORIDA.
>> INSTEAD OF THE DELTA VARIANT,
WHY NOT CALL IT THE DeSANTIS
VARIANT.
>> IN FLORIDA WE HAVE A GOVERNOR
INTERESTED IN PLAYING POLITICS
THAN SAVING LIVES THE DeSANTIS
VARIANT.
>> I THINK IT'S GREAT THE
PRESIDENT HAD A BIRTHDAY PARTY,
GOOD FOR HIM IF YOU'RE
VACCINATED AND WANT TO HAVE A
PARTY AND INVITE PEOPLE TO YOUR
HOUSE, THAT'S FINE, BUT GREG WAS
THIS THE MOST MARINE AND TWO NET
THING WE'VE SEEN.
>> I JUST WANT TO KNOW, WHERE
DID THEY SCALE STUFF BACK.
>> DAVID DIDN'T COME.
>> YEAH, INSTEAD OF THREE
KARDASHIANS THEY SAID WE'RE
PUTTING THE LIMIT ON TWO AND NO
BOTTLE SERVICE AT THE HELIPAD.
THAT WAS IT.
OBAMA JUST TOLD THE REST OF
AMERICA, DON'T JUST LIVE YOUR
LIFE, LIVE YOUR BEST LIFE.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S TELLING YOU.
HE GOES, I AM HAVING A MASSIVE
BIRTHDAY PARTY.
I'M TELLING YOU HALF THE PEOPLE
THERE HE DIDN'T EVEN KNOW,
RIGHT?
BUT HE WASN'T GOING TO CHANGE
ANYTHING.
BUT NOW HE HAS TO DO SOMETHING
ELSE BECAUSE THE PROBLEM WITH
HIM IS HE HAD A MASSIVE BASH
WHILE THE UNVACCINATED RATES IN
THE CITY AMONG BLACKS REMAINS
NEAR 70% AND HE IS SOMEBODY WHO
COULD CHANGE THAT.
SO YOU'RE DONE WITH THE PARTY.
WHY DON'T YOU DO SOMETHING?
WHY DON'T YOU CREATE SOME KIND
OF FREE SPEAKING TOUR RIGHT
INVITE SOME FAMOUS FRIENDS AND
THE ONLY ENTRANCE FEE IS THAT
WHEN YOU'RE IN LINE YOU GET
VACCINATED.
YOU COULD GO TO EVERY INNER
CITY, WHETHER YOU WANT TO DO
MANHATTAN OR OAKLAND, DC,
ATLANTA, DETROIT, HARLEM, BRONX,
WHATEVER.
THE IMPACT COULD BE INCREDIBLE,
HE COULD REALLY DO SOMETHING.
BUT INSTEAD HE'S GOING TO HAVE A
PARTY.
AS FOR THESE OTHER IDIOTS, YOU
KNOW, IT WAS GREAT TO WATCH
ACOSTA THINK THAT THAT WAS
CLEVER.
WHAT IF WE CALL IT THE -- WHAT
WAS IT?
>> DeSANTIS.
ACTUALLY LIKE HE TOOK ONE FROM
COLUMN A AND ANOTHER THING FROM
COLUMN B AND HE PUT IT TOGETHER
AND THOUGHT THAT'S REALLY EDGY
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE DUMB BROAD
FROM THE MORNING DOING THE SAME
THING.
CAN'T REMEMBER HER NAME.
>> AND ALSO, WILL, AS SOON AS
YOU HEARD ANNIE FROM THE NEW
YORK TIMES PROTECTING
CELEBRITIES FROM ANY SCORN
SAYING THEY'RE SOPHISTICATED.
>> SOPHISTICATED CROWD.
>> NOT LIKE THOSE PEOPLE THAT
WENT ON A MOTORCYCLE RIDE IN
STURGIS.
>> RIGHT.
LET'S BE CLEAR WHO WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT, THESE ARE SOPHISTICATED
PEOPLE, VACCINATED PEOPLE.
>> THE ONLY THING IS I'M HAPPY
PRESIDENT OBAMA IS LIVING HIS
BEST LIFE BUT HE'S NOT
ENCOURAGING OTHERS.
>> BY HIS ACTIONS HE IS.
>> BUT BY HIS POLITICAL PARTY
AND POLITICAL IDEOLOGY THEY'RE
SAYING THERE ARE TWO CLASSES OF
PEOPLE IN THIS WORLD.
THIS IS A SEQUEL TO A VERY BAD
MOVIE.
THIS IS COVID PART TWO, THE
DELTA VARIANT.
WE SAW IT IN THE FIRST VERSION,
GAVIN NEWSOME TO THE FRENCH
LAUNDRY, NOW MIRIAM BOWSER
OFFICIATING WEDDINGS MASKLESS
WHILE MASKING DC.
NOW TALKING MASKING CHILDREN IN
THE SCHOOL YEAR WHILE PRESIDENT
OBAMA HAS A PARTY WITH FOUR TO
FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE LARGELY
MASKLESS.
GREAT, LIVE YOUR BEST LIFE.
MAY WE LIVE OUR BEST LIFE AS
WELL?
>> YEAH.
>> I WANT TO PARTY.
>> I THINK EVERYBODY SHOULD BE
LIVING THEIR LIVES NORMALLY.
I THINK THAT THEY SHOULD BE
MOVING ON WITH, WHETHER IT'S
STURGIS OR WHETHER IT'S
PRESIDENT OBAMA HAVING A PARTY.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THE WHITE
HOUSE, THE CDC, DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNORS AROUND THE COUNTRY,
ARE STILL -- THEY STILL HAVE A
BOOT ON PEOPLE'S LIVELIHOODS
BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL
THREATENING THAT IF YOU DON'T DO
THIS OR THIS, WE'RE GOING TO
SHUT YOUR BUSINESS DOWN OR WE'RE
GOING TO IMPLEMENT MANDATES ON
YOU.
AND THE IDEA THAT THEY DO WANT
TO PUT TWO YEAR OLDS AND
CHILDREN IN SCHOOL AND MASK FOR
HOURS ON END WITHOUT ANY REAL
DATA TO BACK UP THAT IT ACTUALLY
WORKS, BY THE WAY, I THINK IS
REALLY APPALLING, AND WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE STANDARD THE MEDIA
HAS, A SOPHISTICATED VACCINATED
CROWD.
THIS IS A CLASS WAR.
YOU KNOW, NANCY PELOSI WANTS
HAIR DRESSERS TO WORK IN
CALIFORNIA WHEN YOU'RE DOING HER
HAIR.
THE D.J. AT THE OBAMA PARTY CAN
D.J. FOR A LARGE GROUP OF 500
PEOPLE DURING COVID AS LONG AS
HE'S WORKING FOR PRESIDENT OBAMA
FOR A PARTY.
BUT IF YOU'RE A D.J. WHO WANTS
TO DO A REGULAR ITALIAN WEDDING
IN NEW JERSEY THERE'S GOING TO
BE RESTRICTIONS ON YOU AND WE
ARE HE NOT GOING TO ALLOW YOU TO
WORK.
AND THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS IS
STILL AMERICA AND AMERICANS ARE
NOT SUBJECTS, THEY ARE CITIZENS
AND THEY CERTAINLY ARE NOT
PEASANTS WHO ARE SUPPOSED TO
PLAY BY A SEPARATE SET OF RULES
THAN THE ELITIST RULING CLASS IN
WASHINGTON OR IN HOLLYWOOD.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THIS IS.
BECAUSE THERE ARE REAL
CONSEQUENCES FOR WORKING PEOPLE
WHO ARE WORRIED ABOUT LOSING
THEIR JOB AGAIN AS A RESULT OF
WHAT PEOPLE LIKE THIS AND THE
DECISIONS THEY ARE MAKING FOR
THEIR LIVES.
>> JESSICA DO YOU THINK
PRESIDENT OBAMA COULD DO
SOMETHING MORE IN TERMS OF
HELPING BLACK AMERICANS BECOME
MORE COMFORTABLE GETTING THE
VACCINE?
>> I THINK HONESTLY ALL OF US
COULD DO SOMETHING MORE.
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY, I LIKE
GREG'S IDEA.
I'M NOT A BLACK AMERICAN BUT I
WOULD GET VACCINATED A SECOND
TIME IF IT MEANT I COULD GO SEE
BARACK OBAMA SPEAK.
WE COULD ALL DO MORE AND THIS
WAS A BIG CONVERSATION EARLY ON
DURING THE PANDEMIC WHEN THE
VACCINE WAS COMING ABOUT HOW THE
PEOPLE THAT WE REALLY NEED TO BE
OUT THERE TALKING ABOUT IT FOR
THE BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES
ARE PEOPLE THAT MATTER TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
SO J Z AND BEYONCE AND LeBRON
JAMES AND WHAT A BIG DEAL IT WAS
WHEN NBA PLAYERS HAD ONE SHOT
AND NOT THE SECOND SHOT AND THEN
PROTOCOLS AND IT'S CONFUSING.
THIS IS A CONFUSING DISEASE AND
YOU SAY IT'S A TERRIBLE SEQUEL,
THE DELTA VARIANT.
IT'S REALLY TERRIBLE, THOUGH,
WHEN -- I'M NOT CALLING IT THE
DeSANTIS STRAIN BUT THERE ARE
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE NOW
HOSPITALIZED IN FLORIDA, AND A
LOT OF THEM CHILDREN.
AND THIS IS WHAT 20% OF THE NEW
CASES OF DELTA ARE AMONGST
CHILDREN AND THAT'S WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT THAT ADULTS ARE
GETTING VACCINATED, THAT YOU DO
YOUR PART AND YOU DO THAT TO
PROTECT YOUR CHILDREN WHO ARE
NOT APPROVED TO HAVE THE VACCINE
YET.
SO I'M ALL FOR A FULL COURT
PRESS ON THE VACCINATION FRONTS,
BUT I DO AGREE, IF HE WANTS TO
HAVE A PARTY, HE SHOULD HAVE IT
OUTSIDE, WHERE WE KNOW IT
DOESN'T GET OUTSIDE.
>> SO WAS STURGIS, STURGIS WAS
ALSO OUTSIDE.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF ANYONE
WATCHED BILL MAHER, HE SHOUTED
OUT LOLLAPALOZZA WHICH WAS A
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT FROM THE LIBERAL
SIDE.
CALL OUT THE BIG PARTY IN
CHICAGO, DON'T JUST CALL OUT A
MOTORCYCLE RALLY.
>> HOW ABOUT WE DON'T CALL OUT
ANYBODY AND LET PEOPLE MAKE
THEIR OWN DECISIONS AND MANAGE
THEIR OWN RISKS.
>> BECAUSE THEY ARE TAKING A
TOLL ON FIRST OF ALL OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
I HEAR FROM COULD BE CON
SIEVETIVES I DON'T WANT TO PAY
FOR YOUR DECISIONS.
WE'RE PAYING FOR PEOPLE IN THE
ICU.
>> WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT FOR 40,
50 YEARS WITH CIGARETTES.
>> AND OBESITY.
>> YEAH.
YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK?
IT WOULD BE GOOD TO HEAR
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS RESPOND TO
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING BECAUSE I
NEVER HEAR THE NUMBERS.
LIKE WHAT'S THE EXACT NUMBER OF
THE CHILDREN WHO'S HOSPITALIZED?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY THE POINT.
>> YEAH, AND I DON'T KNOW AND WE
KNOW THESE KIDS AREN'T SUPPOSED
TO BE VACCINATED AND SO WHAT ARE
WE SUPPOSED TO BE DOING.
BUT I WOULD LOVE TO KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT THE NUMBERS ARE BECAUSE I
ALWAYS FEEL LIKE YOU'RE NOT
TELLING US.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT GREG.
THIS ISN'T A STORY ABOUT
VACCINATION THIS IS A STORY
ABOUT REALITY.
THE POINT IS THE ELITE LIKE
PRESIDENT OBAMA ARE NOT LIVING
LIKE DELTA VARIANT IS THIS
INCREDIBLY SCARY THING THAT
THEY'RE SAYING.
PRESIDENT WHEN WE MAKE DECISIONS
FOR OUR CHILDREN IN ALL HONESTY
AND CURIOSITY, I WANT TO KNOW
THE NUMBERS THAT GREG POINTS
OUT, I WANT TO KNOW THE
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND MORTALITY
FOR DELTA AND THE REST OF COVID
IN THE NUMBERS.
BECAUSE WHAT I HAVE SEEN IS IT'S
LESS LETHAL HAS LESS OF AN
EFFECT ON HOSPITALIZATIONS THAN
THE COMMON FLU.
>> WE DO KNOW IT IS NOT A
PROBLEM FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
VACCINATED.
SO IF YOU'RE WATCHING PLEASE GET
YOURSELF VACCINATED IF YOU'RE 12
OR OTHER.
WE KNOW THERE ARE MORE CASES OF
CHILDREN BEING REPORTED IN LACES
LIKE FLORIDA, IN LIBERAL AS
WELL, CALIFORNIA, NEW YORK,
ARKANSAS A DOCTOR THERE PLEADING
TO GET VACCINATED BECAUSE THEY
ARE OVERRUN.
I BELIEVE THE NUMBERS ARE
AVAILABLE, I WILL TEXT YOU LATER